we turn to uh one of the best in the
business
pleased to have as my first guest here
of super bowl week
on behalf of the snickers hungriest
player of the year award
from the arizona cardinals the offensive
rookie of the year last year
kyler murray how are you doing kyler
you doing good how are you i'm doing
better for talking to you so kyler
are you going to play baseball or
football
oh i'm i won't play baseball i'm sorry
i'm sorry
these are my questions from super bowl i
still have my list of questions from
super bowl 53 i'm going to place those
aside
for the moment when was the last time
you thought
buddy okay kyle i'm just trying um so
when was the last time you threw a
baseball
when's the last time that happened
man um i
couldn't tell you no kidding us yeah
yeah i think
i don't remember all right all right and
the last time you threw a football was
week 17 correct
no i've thrown the ball recently okay
good so i guess that's how
my first question is for you how are you
feeling how are you feeling physically
right now off of the season the the
rigors of that season
kyler oh i mean
mentally i feel good physically you know
got hurt obviously that last
uh you know on the first drive of the
last game um just rehabbing
and then um you know once once i get
back to 100 you know hit the ground
running
um start working out again and stuff
like that but
mentally i'm i'm feeling good obviously
disappointing into the season
um but i think you know we made strides
in the right direction
that's not what it's about but you know
we didn't know what we wanted to get to
i think we got a lot you know a lot of
work to do to get to you know
playing this week so so that's my
question for you is now you got stafford
in your division we all know that the
49ers are going to come back healthy and
we all know again
what seattle is going to do um
what steps of improvement for you
personally do you think you can make
and will make in the 2021 season kyla
murray
me personally i believe uh just really
really taking care of the ball i think
the plays are there to be made
um and you know i think i made you know
i made a jump out of this from year one
year two
but i think there's more there's even
more pledge to be made
um as a whole as a team i think you just
you know
take care of the little things um make
more attention to detail and really
respect the little things because
um ultimately you know those those add
up and i think that came back to bite us
in the second half of the season
um where you know we ended up not making
playoffs whereas we felt
um at the beginning we were easily going
to make it so
it's um we got a lot of work to do we
just got to get
we got to get better all around so what
is the little thing
can you give me an example of one of the
little things kyler that came back to
bike
you know i i believe we you know we
pretty sure we led the league in
penalties and you
you know that's not winning football
that's not championship football
um and no no sport ever if you lead the
league and
philosophies are um are you going to be
probably as successful as you want to be
so that's that's just one of the areas
but um
you know i think as a team man like i
said you know we're playing i think the
toughest division in nfl
um and like you said the 49ers come back
healthy
the rams just had a great great guy and
great quarterback in that stafford
the seahawks obviously you know they're
consistent
um and you know we we gotta match that
uh
match that intensity in that energy so
kyla murray here on the rich eisen show
on behalf of the snickers hungriest
player of the year award and we'll get
to that
in a second um so uh
when you know big life-changing moments
potentially or
or memorable moments happen you
definitely remember where you were when
you first learned about it so where were
you when you learned that deandre
hopkins was coming to arizona
kyler i was in
i was in dallas texas i just got done
with a workout
this was two weeks prior to the
announcement actually so
you know once i i saw the text come
across my phone i couldn't i couldn't
believe it you know just because i was
he was the last person that i was
expecting his name to come across my
phone and when it did
um i i immediately went to youtube check
it you know watch his highlights already
knew he was capable of
you know what type of guy player he is
but you know you just i just had to go
go watch for myself and um it was a
great day for sure
so you have you kept that under your hat
for two weeks
before it was announced or man it was it
was tough just because
it was it was tough because i felt like
i was being lied to
every day kept passing by and i was like
like
when the hell are y'all gonna announce
like is is it ever gonna happen
and um yeah so that was that was the
story
especially for a second round pick kyler
i mean that's just
insanity that that's crazy and then
right and then for your second year to
to have deandre hopkins at your
in your in your huddle at your at your
disposal
um and then there was that moment i
think it was against dallas
can you walk me through where you it
looked like you were smiling because you
knew he was open
and you didn't even grip the ball by the
strings you threw it to him is that what
happened
in that game tyler no i was i wouldn't
say that was a thursday night against
the uh seattle seahawks okay
right but um yeah no i
i don't know where the smiling came from
i think that was just a facial
expression that i made
um but you know that was a plain
practice where
um you know we looked up to the sideline
and snapped the ball unexpectedly
and um i knew i knew once i had
one-on-one it was it was pretty much a
wrap
so that's a good feeling to have a guy
out there that that can catch the ball
wherever you throw it
and it it appears do you think that
larry fitzgerald is going to step away
carla murray what's your sense on that
right now
you got to set me up i i honestly don't
know i don't know
i mean i know he's capable of coming
back and playing um
you know but that's you know that's
that's uh
where he's gonna make that decision he's
obviously a legend regardless what he
does
um you know i would love to have him
back but yeah that's that's on him
i don't mean to set you up i'm just just
sussing out what you're no
no and i i totally understand i'm
putting you in a position where you
might retire him
and it's his decision to make and to
announce and he's and he's a really
special guy but
i guess my question i don't want him to
go you know what i mean like i don't
want him to leave he's
he's still got enough and he's so damn
special what has he brought to
you what has he taught you what have you
gleaned from him kyler murray
have you gleaned from him yeah i mean i
i i get what you say i feel like it's
like a
like watching a lebron you know kind of
retire type of thing like d
wade or you know one of those like one
of those guys
um finally you know putting the cleats
up it'd probably be sad
um because i've been watching my whole
life so until now being you know be in
the locker room with him and play with
him is you know even crazier
um you know he's meant a lot he means a
lot to the organization
um he means a lot to the state of
arizona obviously you know everybody
calls him
larry but he's got a nickname um you
know he's been great throughout the
community and stuff like that like i
said i mean
he's treated like a king um so it would
you know it'd be unfortunate to lose him
for sure but um like i said he's gonna
make the decision for himself
and uh you know i'll be i'll be rocking
with him regardless of what he does so
so let's talk about your snickers
hungriest player of the uh
the year award you won the chain in week
10 of the regular season
um i believe that was the hail murray
moment correct yep that part it was
to that chain um 60 grand that chain is
worth what was it like to
to have that um piece of jewelry kyler
with that play
there's an honor um you know the week 10
against the bills
um i had a pretty good game so i was i
was honestly like
it wasn't in my eyes it wasn't the
craziest game uh
statistically but you know i was
surprised i got you know i won this
award but you know like i said it's an
honor to win it
um like you said value that you know
sixty thousand dollars
um made by ben baller it's it's uh
right i don't know if you've ever seen
it but it's it's a it's a beautiful
chain
um it's around my neck right now so i
feel pretty good
okay it's on you around your neck right
now can you describe it for me kyler
i've seen it but what does it look like
from your perspective
i mean it's gone it's got hungry on it
um it's got you know the azka snickers
logo
uh i wish i could show it to you but um
right it's uh it's got twenty three
hundred stones there thirty pair
thirty day carrot um you know and i get
the uh
you know done at the first funds in
arizona so it's a it's a great deal
all right well you could take a picture
of it and at rich eisen show
from at k1 you know we'll take that for
sure and then we'll retweet it
it's called going video i'll load that
up in a minute
i appreciate that kyle that would be
great now just like all sorts of great
plays and great throws
were you staring at the ground when when
uh deandre
high pointed that one were you were you
on the ground where were
did you see it did you look up at the
screen walk me through the
hail murray from your perspective yeah i
uh i actually
i got the um we actually got a video on
the angle of like
of just me you know when when the play
happened so
um everybody kept asking me afterwards
and i gave him like multiple different
answers because i didn't know
until i saw the video it happened so
fast like you know it was one of those
moments where
usually you're watching youtube or
watching you know watching the tv when
it happens
for myself to actually be in the in the
moment
it was pretty crazy and uh i think i
watched on the big screen now that's
what the video the video show release
i'm kidding
i don't know if you're aware uh a kyler
um when you completed that pass
you didn't just win the game for the
arizona cardinals you won the game for
uh fantasy leagues for me uh my buddy
chris brockman
um tj jefferson our social media
grandmaster literally all three of us
you won the game for us because we all
were wise enough to draft kyler murray
in our draft this year i just
wanted to get some points for that i
appreciate it i appreciate it appreciate
you
oh my gosh no right right back at you uh
so that was 43 yards how far can you
throw a football
what's the what what what do you got for
me no honestly i don't even know come on
come on i'm i honestly yeah i have no
idea come on it's not like i'm asking
how far you can throw a baseball how far
can you throw a football
come on what do you got come on connor
i i'm not one of those big man i'm not
one of those girls out like
you know i lost the ball but i would i
would say i would say 60
you know 60 um around there
okay so uh kingsbury's just got to get
you
to the what your own 40 your own 35
that we're good is that what you're
saying for future i might need a little
bit more i might
i might the 35 that's it that's that's a
long throw
okay that's like a cordell throw i guess
from back in the day but
okay yeah like i might need a little
more uh
okay a little more than that okay before
i let you go sir give me a super bowl 55
prediction
who do you think takes it on sunday kyla
murray
uh obviously both great teams um
well i'm gonna go with i'm gonna go with
tom brady
why is that you gotta go with tom yeah
that's it just tb you're the michigan
guy too so
i think you like that oh you know you're
talking my language kyla murray come on
now look at you buttering me up
but and i appreciate that um so that's
you're gonna go with him just because
he's just
tom brady he can't go against him we got
any x's and o's thoughts on it or
whatever
happened i was rooting for aaron rodgers
and you know they ended up losing so
um kind of the nfc thing um you know i'm
going with uh
i'm good i and i mean you don't really
you know it's kind of
frowned upon to go against bet against
brady you know he's uh
one of this i i saw a stat like he's
just 10 10 super bowls or something
crazy like that
um oh he just finds a way to win that's
what the bearings do
you know that's just that's that's who
he is so well i mean to
to just giving in perspective as to what
he's doing right now
for you to play in the super bowl at
brady's age you will have to start super
bowl 75
kyler that's a fact i'm not that's not
an exaggeration that would be the number
super bowl 75 yes if you match brady
by starting for the nfc a super bowl
yes if for you to match him to play at
his age
in for the nfc in the super bowl you
will have to be the starting quarterback
of super bowl 75. that's a fact
isn't that crazy yeah i gotta i'm i'm
i'm i'm on the chase right now
well okay at least the first things
first
right first things first is offensive
rookie of the year and then snickers
hungriest player of the year
connor i appreciate the time uh and also
the thrills on behalf of all of our
fantasy teams and just being a fan of
the nfl
i just love watching you play so let's
uh let's stay in touch let's do this
more than once every two years
if you don't mind sir okay
and it's at rich eisenhower for the
photograph
oh yeah i got you okay thank you kyla
murray appreciate it that's kylie murray
right here
on if you will at rich eisenhower that's
at k1 hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here